From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History
and Culture.
Three, two, one, on rolling.
Today is Saturday, March 9, 2013.
My name is Assam Kwame Jeffries of the Ohio State University and the Southern oral history
program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with videographer, Petna Dalico in Albany, Georgia on the campus of Albany State University
to conduct an interview for the Civil Rights History Project which is a joint undertaking
of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library
of Congress.
We are here this afternoon with Lucius Holloway, Senior and Emma K. Holloway.
Thank you so much for joining us and for sharing your story and the history of the movement
with us.
Thank you for having us.
Mr. Holloway, where and when were you born?
I was born in Teo, Canada, Austin, Georgia in 1932.
And your parents?
What were their names?
My parents was my father was Bobby Holloway, Senior and my mother was Louise, Thorne and
Holloway.
What did they do?
Share croppers.
So you grew up on the farm?
I grew up on the farm.
At heart, the way.
The heart away.
It was a haze cropping.
They paved all of the bills and at the end of the year they'd take that out and if anything
was left, you divide it, but it was never anything left.
You always broke ebony.
And life on the farm, I mean you grew up doing what kinds of things.
With your dad working in the field, I'm assuming?
Right.
Well, life on the farm, back in, I would say at least 35, that would give me at least to
be three years old and on up 35, six and 37, during that time.
Now it was good because that's all I knew.
So life was good.
I had something to eat and play to sleep and loving parents.
So if I look at it right then and forget about today, it was good.
Because you know that far back, out those privileged moves was just like inside today.
Ocea and Mochaelog, you know, it was fine.
But if I look at it then, forget today.
What was life like away from the farm in Tarot County?
That was not much of a life away from the farm because it's a tear kind of with soap
farming, till even red up town south.
So that was cotton and combing red up to the streets and the new state was all around
it.
So you never got out of the mode of farming.
It was farming in an era where you look even going to church once a month, you're
old the way.
So farming was embedded in you.
That's all the war.
That's all the war's farming.
So we had to like it.
We was born in it.
We was growing up in it.
And it was good then.
Very good.
Now you eventually will serve in a military.
When did you, when did your service begin?
My military service began in June of 1952.
That's when military time started.
And my only reason for going to the military was because my parents, like I said, they worked
most of them in their lives, they had farming and they had very little in them and it was
a whole bunch of us.
So that was one of my ways.
I was hired.
I did it.
Somebody needed somebody to work.
He hired me.
I worked and I brought a chick home.
They wouldn't even know chicks then they paid cash money in our brown emerald.
So I brought that home.
And the good and military to me was a better way to help support my family.
And I enlisted in, I was born in June and 19, 1952.
And at that time a private in the military was drawing $60 a month.
So that was a big pile of money for me.
And it was so large till when I went to talk about making a lot of money.
Till my parents, I said to the recruiter, I went to send my mother on a lot.
And of course I couldn't, I had to send a class A, not a class Q. A class Q a lot of
money during that time was who you sent it to was the dependent of yours.
My parents wouldn't independent on me.
So I had to send a class A a lot of them.
And that meant whatever I send they didn't match it.
So I was getting $60 a month, I sent my mother for it.
He said, you crazy, how can you live out of $20 a month?
I said, I can't.
And I did.
Now, during your time in the military that you met the future Mrs.
Holloway?
No, it was after my time.
I met her in 1955, June.
And I had never seen, never heard, never thought of her before the first day I saw her.
But that's when I met her about the last, I was discharged, probably June in 1955.
I got home, could have been the 20th of June, probably, either the morning, the evening
of the 20th or the evening of the 21st of 55 when I met her.
Mrs. Holloway, will you?
From Tau County as well?
Yes, I was.
Born in the County.
Born in Tau County.
And do you remember when you met?
I remember when I met him.
And I was in high school.
And I was in the 11th grade.
And I had taken on a job working at a cafe, Richmond's Cafe on Main Street.
But I was a farmer.
I picked cotton every day.
I was my dad's best cotton picker.
I picked a 400 pound cotton today.
And I could pick more than my brother.
And I loved it.
My dad, I loved it for him to come to the cotton patch, where we were because he worked
it in the cotton patch.
And my mother also worked in the cotton patch.
We found it.
And we had moved to Dawson, Georgia, Tau County.
And he was still farming, but he moved in the city.
My mother kept telling my dad, James, you need to get something or your own.
James, you need to get some or your own.
So my mother went to work at a house where dad was renting land from this white man in
Frank Smith.
The first year that we moved to this farm and dad was farming with this white man, we
did good.
Dad made a profit.
That year he made that profit, the man that we was farming for, find out that my dad
had said that that year he was going to buy him a house.
So that year, dad had worked at that farm.
The man took most of the farm and we come out there to make $600.
He gave it to his wife, my mother.
My mother went to town and she bought this hunt.
They purchased this hunt.
It was kind of shelling, but they bought it because we needed someone to stay because
dad was coming from the farm to come to town to do public work and he started at the
meal where they jinn and cock.
And my mother went to the hospital as a dietician cooking for the hospital.
And at that time, when I went to work to get little items to buy for school because we
loved it school and my mother there loved to go to school.
So when I got this little job, my husband came in from the military.
I thought he told me he was a military boy.
And I was walking home that evening from my job and this car, shelling loud, young and
brown rolled up behind me.
I kind of looked around and I saw his man in his car.
He said, hey, I said, hey, hello, how you doing?
He said, would you like a ride, huh?
I looked at him.
He had on his soul to do the farm.
I said, no.
My mother do not lie me to ride with boys plus the one in the military because they don't
do them a come on and get good friends.
So no.
And so when I walked on and he rolled on slowly, he asked me where I live.
He rolled slowly behind me until I got home.
And then he found out where I lived and he asked me could he come visit me.
So yeah, you could come visit me.
So he started visiting me and he was coming so regular to regular.
I told him, don't you think he just slowed down?
I told my mother, don't want me to go everyday because I told her that we had to milk them
cows and get that milk and bring in children from the woods and have a fight.
So he did start coming in the evening and he would stay from maybe I said seven to nine
and when nine come, I started looking at that clock.
My mother don't lie to that.
I don't come and I know that it's nine o'clock.
But nine o'clock come, that boy had to be out of there.
So he would come and he would stay tonight and he lived and he came to about a year and
then he has to marry him.
I was in the 12th grade and we got married in June 57 and my aunt had told me that when
I graduated from high school, she wanted me to go to a beautician because that's what
I like I like doing here.
So she told me, when you get out, just go to school.
I said, yes ma'am, I'll be glad they go to college for a college for a college.
So he wanted to marry me and I told him what I said, I couldn't marry because I had to
go to school.
The college in my aunt was going to pay for it.
So he told my mother and my father that he would pay for me going to school because of
a college in he would marry me.
So he did, we got married in June 57 and I came home.
So two years we started having our children.
I had, my first was a girl, my second was a boy, Lucia Jr.
My third was a girl, Charlene, my fourth was my baby, Patrick and that was in 64.
So he was going to military school.
So he paid for me to go to Cosmatallegic at Albany Tech College at that time and I went
for beautiful country and I graduated with Master Cosmatallegic at Lyson and I started
my business and he built a business for me to do hair and I was a very successful beautician
to help him raise our children because he was fired from the post office because he
was involved with voter stretching movement.
He was, he was in the movement with SCLC and he was getting people's register to vote.
So if we voted registered and voted, we would not have such a hard time because the white
people didn't want you to register and vote because they weren't going to keep you down.
So you would be enslaved in the cotton patches and comb patches and doing all that stuff.
So that was the reason why he was working so hard so we could get people registered
but they could better themselves and get good education so we wouldn't have to do all
this stuff that we do.
Being dogged out and punished and beaten and dragged up and down in the streets and all
of that kind of stuff and so I went and I got finished and got my license and started
doing hair.
But when I started to do hair, the people, they didn't like that too well because they
knew the white people had told them that don't fool around with the Halloween because
bad thing was going on and they home getting people's register to vote and y'all don't need
your register and y'all don't need to vote for any of the stations like y'all is done.
So my custom was limited but we didn't pay that in attention.
I just kept on doing and kept on working and kept on going to the SCLC organizations
that they had what he was involved with until it got real, real crucious as we stayed
in it.
He was threatened.
They took the gas tank from our house that cold at night and we had it with our baby.
I was there and we just getting cold up.
The cold is night and that year and 59 on my first shy come and it was cold and I had
the baby lame on the lap and he said it was cold.
I said, do you hear the cold in the house?
He said, I just built a tank up with gas and the people that bring the gas out here.
I said, but ain't no gas and that cost the cold steel getting dark and darker.
He went out and looked.
The old wife, he had come there and cut that gas and I had loose from our house and left
and we did not have no gas.
It was cold and a friend of ours that next day had our old time here that you could put
care singing in.
So she let us use that care and sing heater until we could get to get some heat and
it was hard for my husband to get out and get heat and stuff like that at that time.
So somebody then had a cold heater.
They had to cut a hole through the house to put a wooden heater in there for us to get
the wood to put in there to have heat for a while.
Then it went on.
We went to the, kept going to the movements and things.
They told him he went to work one day.
He was working at the post office.
He said, well, he didn't have no job down on the move.
And they told him he didn't have no job.
They said that he had over put more time down and he's supposed to have the get a chance
to fight him, but he hadn't did that.
But that's what they did to get him fired from their job.
So they got in fight.
So then after they got him fired from their job, he kept still getting people's rage
that the boy was still.
He didn't give up.
He just still was fighting for the rights of getting people's rage and vote.
And this night, but I knew that we was going to die just felt that we was going to be
here this particular night.
He came home and he said that he was going to that meeting that night.
And there's white people, white people that are all they to work for in our community.
She cooked it for those people.
And those people told her that there was going to kill Lucius Holloway that night because
they tied that mess of he getting people's rage.
She didn't vote it and these niggles don't need to be no rage.
They don't vote anything.
Just like they are.
And she come down and she told she built him.
She said, Holloway, please don't go to the meeting tonight.
Lucius said this was the day I got to go.
So she said, all right, I don't want you to get really in the night.
So that night arrived seven o'clock.
My husband came in and he told me, y'all get really everywhere my husband went.
I don't know why he wanted to kill me and I'm chilling with him and drive us to go.
But I think that was to have more spirit.
He had his family with him.
He was covered to know the spirit.
But he didn't realize the God had his back.
I was back.
And we went on that night to this church to call mine all about this church and say I'm
so George.
I had them four kids sitting with me on this bench in the church.
And we went in that church.
It was some boys on the outside of Wonder Boy.
Knocked on the one and said, Ms. Holloway, don't sit side of that one.
She said, cause the people I can't let you go ride.
They were going to kill tonight.
And my husband, I had a friend that had been in the military.
And he came to that movement meeting that night.
And when he came, he got to my husband and he said, Lucius, I don't know, but they go
to kill y'all tonight.
I was just nervous and scared as I could be.
But I didn't just say whatever happened, got to have him.
So he told my husband, he said, you give me your key, your cock key.
He said, you take my car.
And when you leave him, you go the way you were safe.
I'm going to take your car and I'm going to go back the way you can.
So that young man, Herschen, Blacks, he gave Lucius that car.
So people come in at night at church.
They raided at church.
They had gun.
Had him copped.
The shoot air about it.
The shirah, the char sihrah, and them, the SCLC movement.
People, they were there at night, two all of them.
And the way we were safe, we got in this car.
And we went the other way around, along the way around.
And when this young man got an hour car and went back the way we came from Dawson by
the creek, the police and all, just a gang of us sitting down there waiting the shooting
killers.
And when they got that, he was told, he's flashlights in these men's face, in this young man's
face in our car.
He said, you ain't the niggum looking for, I'm looking for that Lucius Hollywood.
We're going to kill him tonight and say, where is he?
You had him.
He said that he had to go pick up some flyers for a meeting.
Some flyers for a meeting.
And he said, yes, yes sir.
And so they had Rastem.
Because he figured that they had outsmarted up and we was in a car, but they didn't have
no way of knowing they just took what the man said.
And we came on round through back side of Lee Cannon.
I took us about like three hours to get to our house and it was about 30 minutes to get
that otherwise.
But we were safe that night.
They didn't kill us that night.
And next week or two, they came to the house and my husband always sent me to answer the
door.
This man came to kill him that night.
And when I went to the door, somebody knocked on the door and he said, go to the door.
We would just be real still and go and be by that night.
I peeped out.
This man had come to kill him.
But he would answer no no.
And I peeped out and I saw this man kneeling down at our door and nobody said that we went
back in the house and I told him about this man about him.
So we just got still.
Some of them went up on the bed, carried the children up on the bed and we just paced
there.
And then next day, when he got up and went to the post office, I think that the next day
the same man was around after killing.
But the man said later that he just couldn't kill him.
And he went on and moved out of town because I think the white folk ran him out of there
because he didn't kill my husband.
And thank God we still alive.
His story is along the mountain.
But some of my I could remember and some of that didn't because I was just so scared and
so frightened about what happened.
Just because we went to register and both.
But we could better hide ourselves and help people in the community as we did.
But we still hold people in our community.
We still there and we still have people.
And I think all of this because it's all about him.
Right?
And let me face forward real fast.
The pickup on that.
She didn't tell you.
She gave me an ultimatum.
She said you got to two things before I marry.
You got to get out and I'm in them one.
And I didn't want to do that.
And then we two helped me through school.
But I'd give them up.
But that was sometime in 55.
It was just a few days later I met three men on a conversation.
Addinette with you pull them in M.G.
Hall.
And of course, I was in a dos teach of it.
And only spot in 1955.
The Krell's dinner in the NAACP appointed me his first vice president in 1955.
A position that I have been in ever since.
Now he got beat up to that.
But he died from it.
That may be the young president for a little while.
So we got another man, J.O.
Born for president.
I fell back to first vice president.
He served faith for several years.
And he got killed.
Right in office.
He killed dead.
I served at the young until he was buried in the guy.
So as we speak, Ezekahale is the president of NAACP.
I'm still first vice president.
I've been sitting in 1955.
But it was all about the whole thing was about the vote.
So I stayed on course, spied all of the threats I had on my life.
I stayed on the course about all the lawsuits, black men and black women, they backtalk.
And it dulls them.
I would be told in any time if I was walking down the street and some black folks met me,
they were wrong the other side.
They thought I said, well, I'm black folks, shoot you.
I don't want to get shot.
So if I would walk up in the church or on the crowd, they would just get away from me.
So I was just like a so famous standing there by myself.
But as my wife said, I never stopped.
I never give it up.
And they all went on ease the nights and days.
I was just scared as they're the other human.
I was human.
But I went along with it.
I had a couple of black men to, to, was paid the shootment.
All I said paid, maybe they wouldn't, but they was told because they said they were.
But I never was shot.
I lived through it.
And as a result of the filing the lawsuits and all this kind of thing in Tear Accounting,
we were able to get black folks elected to positions.
They get black folks appointed to position.
And as we speak right now, we pretty much dominate the electric and the seat of those
in Tear Accounting.
We got black folks in all faith elected positions.
And some of this kind of leadership, we had a black man elected male for about 22 plus years.
And of course he got, comfortably got too, comfortably, too selfish.
We voted him out the other day.
We got a young 22 year old black man, but I have a man very happy for him.
And I served four years on the City Council.
I'm rather than my 17th and a half year on the Board of County Commissioners.
And I'm on every board that yields an, an every organization that we didn't think.
And I tell them all the time, one time back in the middle six, I tried to join the Cookler
clan, but they wouldn't let me.
So I'm really saying that I was a part of everything.
And it went in a selfish way.
You know, I did it to help the people.
I've always, from nine years old, it's far back, because I can remember.
I always had to decide to help people.
I always thought it was a better way and a better time.
And being in the military, I could see things different of the states and cities.
I could see people don't live in better than they were in Tear County.
And I say if you can do it, and stop scrolling on it, if you can do it in Maryland, if you can
do it in Korea, if you can do it in the Moanjire, and if you can do it in Bundria, Spain,
you can do it in Los Angeles.
So I stayed on it.
And I'm very, I'm very excited and thankful to God that a lot of things that I wake for
some 57, 58 years ago, I'm seeing it in the fluision.
And it's time, if you'd asked me what you see it, I said, no, but it will happen.
But I'm actually seeing it.
And it's amazing to wake up every morning and see things that 55, 56 years ago that I
was struggling for, men's died, raising Tear County, trying to do the same thing.
And I got an article over there in Tau Laeice Man standing.
And when you read through the whole article, and they said, man, it's Lucius Holloway, because
it was four of us, three of them dead, two of them got killed, one died naturally.
Of course, on the Laeice Man standing, I don't know how I'll go, my died naturally, I might
get shot of.
I just don't know, but right now on the Laeice Man standing, they never did anything big
for Tear County.
Some of the fugitives come in later on and do something, but they were just like rappers.
They hopped about the dead and wrong.
Some of them even left the state, and some of them gradually come left the city, and
some of them gradually come back.
We had to sell about two families left the state, and we had any number of them left the
city.
And they gradually come back, and everything, it's smoothed off.
And the plaintiff got up to 40,000 feet, and he had to sit on the crew, and the students
said, unbucket your belts, they come back.
They come back.
But I'm very humble, I'm very happy, and I'm very blessed to even just sit here now and
talk about it.
For the past few years, I've been from place to place.
I even wrote a book, The Siller Ripes Through The Eyes of Lucius Holloway.
Of course, I had that five, six of them this morning, and they all went fast as somebody
knew I had them.
But I wrote that book, and a lot of the things we're talking about is in there.
And I'm just, as I said, I'm almost blessed and thankful that I'm able to see you.
Let me just ask you one last question.
What would you like children, the younger generation today, to know about what you all went
through over the years, but really during the height of the movement in the 60s?
I would like for them to know that my family, although I was dispoken, I was the one doing
everything, but they were there.
So that's just like they were saying what I'm going to say.
I would like for the young children's, boys and girls to know today, number one, trusting
God, for what you want.
And stay focused.
You believe in, stay with them.
I would like for them to know that.
And when they know that, then they will begin to achieve.
Mrs. Holloway.
Same thing.
What would you like of children of today, young people of today, to know about what you
went through during the movement?
I would like for the young people today, is to know that they can make a difference.
If they be obedience, respect the elder and respect themselves, and try to get a good education
and stay in school and be honorable to themselves, because you got to respect yourself before
you go anywhere.
Respect themselves and education is the key to being successful from the wound to the
left, from the left to toddlers, training and listening and opening.
And they will make it.
And trust God.
Mr. Holloway, Mrs. Holloway, thank you so much for sharing your story.
Good.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.